salut pour le premier épisode de ce
nouveau format
j'aimerais vous proposer une petite
introduction à une des écoles
philosophiques les plus marquantes de la
grèce antique le stoïcisme
je suis fasciné par les stoïciens mais
je ne suis pas un expert
alors j'ai fait appel à adam drewnowski
spécialiste du tourisme justement ça
tombe bien pour rappel c'est une vidéo
de niveau 1
donc normalement accessible à tous il ya
une bibliographie dans la description et
si vous voyez apparaître un chiffre
entre parenthèses comme ça quand je
parle c'est l'équivalent d'une note de
bas de page
et elle se trouve aussi dans la
description voici le plan de cette vidéo
d'abord une petite présentation pour ce
match dans le bain ensuite on verra le
rôle singulier que joue la raison pour
les stoïciens ce qui nous permettra
ensuite d'aborder les enjeux éthiques
cette philosophie la question de la
connaissance et l'interdépendance de ces
deux dimensions
et pour finir on présentera la dimension
pratique de cette philosophie et le sens
qu'elle peut avoir aujourd'hui alors le
stoïcisme est une école ancien de pensée
philosophique fondée au 3e siècle avant
jésus-christ par et non de six tubes son
élève crise y eut également un rôle
essentiel dans le façonnement de la
doctrine les premiers stoïciens était
bien sûr influencé par les philosophies
précédente
et l'on peut dire que ces noms font son
école en réaction critique au platonisme
par exemple les platonicien pense selon
un dualisme ontologique le monde
sensible accessible à nos sens n'existe
pas en tant que tel parce qu'il est en
perpétuel devenir qu'il ne cesse de se
transformer il n'a pas de réelle
identité
seules existent à proprement parler les
essences des choses qui sont toujours
telles qu'elles sont
ne changeront jamais
qui pour cette raison sont
imperceptibles est donc purement
intelligible au contraire pour le
stoïcisme tout ce qui est perceptible et
seulement ce qui est perceptible
existe il n'ya pas d'essence au delà de
ce que l'on peut percevoir
autre exemple les platonicien pente
également un dualisme anthropologique
l'âme immortelle d'un être humain est
séparé est séparable de son corps mortel
au contraire pour les stoïciens l'âme
est encore dans le corps et le jour venu
elle meurt en même temps que le corps
organique les stoïciens attache une
grande importance au fait d'accorder la
théorie avec la pratique et c'est ce qui
rend fascinante cette philosophie pour
beaucoup d'entre nous le plus important
à leurs yeux et l'éthique au sens propre
c'est à dire la manière que l'on a de
conduire sa vie
la question centrale est de savoir
comment mener sa vie de la meilleure
manière possible et il considère qu'on
ne peut répondre à cette question sans
interroger un la physique c'est-à-dire
le fonctionnement du monde et 2
la logique c'est à dire les moyens par
lesquels l'être humain résonnent les
limites de l'esprit humain
ces trois dimensions éthiques physique
logique se déterminent mutuellement
ce qui distingue le stoïcisme des écoles
rivales se sont un des positions qui
peuvent paraître provocatrice
même si elles sont toujours solidement
argumentée de un rationalisme à toute
épreuve et 3 des histoires relatant des
faits vécus par les stoïciens est dans
la force mentale frappe l'imaginaire
hier comme aujourd'hui pour les
stoïciens la nature des choses est régi
par la causalité
c'est à dire que toute chose à une cause
et elle est elle même une cause pour une
autre chirurgie cette causalité répond à
un principe rationnelle le logos c'est
ce qu'ils organisent l'univers où le
cosmos le gros c'est donc la rationalité
et la nature est rationnel les être
pourvus eux-mêmes de rationalité peuvent
comprendre la nature et peuvent
appréhender le principe organisateur de
l'univers les stoïciens pensait que les
êtres de deux raisons sont capables de
discerner le vrai du faux et donc
d'atteindre la connaissance ce qui les
oppose à leurs contemporains et critique
les sceptiques
chose importante à souligner les
stoïciens avait cette croyance très
moderne selon laquelle la connaissance
ne peut être atteinte qu'en soumettant
son expertise au jugement collectif ce
qui rappelle la méthodologie
scientifique moderne évidemment une
chose à clarifier d'anglais concerne le
mythe selon lequel le stoïcien
ressemblerait à monsieur spock non le
stoïcisme ne suppose pas de vivre sans
la moindre émotion
et de poursuivre son existence comme une
sorte de robot analytique c'est ce qu'on
verra plus en détail dans la partie de
la vidéo consacrée à la pratique éthique
pour les stoïciens la philosophie n'est
pas un champ de connaissance ou un passe
temps mais une manière de vivre
c'est à la fois une pratique et un
exercice dans le but d'identifier ce qui
est bénéfique comprendre le monde et
parvenir à identifier ce qui est bon et
mauvais cela demande une grande
discipline
mais le jeu en vaut la chandelle puisque
ce n'est rien de moins que la liberté
qui est visé
la raison logos en grec est centrale
dans le stoïcisme
c'est elle qui donne sa forme et sa
constitution à toute chose tout ce qui
existe n'est pas doué de raison c'est à
dire capable de raisonner mais tout ce
qui existe et rationnelle parce que
toute chose à une raison toute chose est
causée par quelque chose et et cause de
quelque chose donc toute chose joue un
rôle dans une grande chaîne causale
l'ordre national du cosmos correspond à
l'ensemble des chaînes cozad même un
grain de sable
on dira qu'il est rationnel parce qu'il
participe pleinement à l'ordre cosmique
comme l'être humain la chance de l'être
humain
à la différence du grain de sable s'est
donc de pouvoir prendre conscience de
cet ordre qui peut tenter de représenter
les structures internes qui régissent le
cosmos grâce au langage le langage ne
fait que suivre les articulations ce
truc qui structure le réel nous disons
le soleil brille parce que dans la
réalité le phénomène de brillance et
provoqué par le soleil en ce sens le
langage exprime les relations des choses
entre elles l'être humain a cette
particularité qu'il a accès aux
structures de l'univers parce que ces
structures sont exprimable et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que fait la science
aujourd'hui elle décrit dans un langage
aussi rationnel que possible
loin de l'univers cela ne veut pas dire
que cette structure passionnel est
dépendant du langage le langage humain
est en fait qu'une chose rationnelle
parmi toutes les choses qui constituent
l'univers mais avec cette particularité
fascinante de pouvoir refléter
l'organisation de l'univers la logique
du langage est une image de la logique
du groupe d'ailleurs l'être humain n'est
pas le paradigme de la rationalité pour
les stoïciens le modèle type ce sont les
corps célestes les planètes et les
étoiles n'utilise pas de langage mais
leur comportement ne déroge jamais aussi
vaste et vieux que sur l'univers à un
ordre et une régularité sans faille
une telle conception de la raison
conduit à prendre conscience que la
place de l'homme n'est pas central dans
le cosmos elle est relative à tout ce
qui existe pour les stoïciens il faut
garder cela à l'esprit si l'on veut
définir les capacités et les limites du
maine si on se trompe sur la place de
l'homme dans le monde
on risque de se tromper sur tout un tas
de problèmes très importants comme ceux
que l'on peut espérer accomplir ce que
l'on est en droit d'attendre de nous
mêmes ce que l'on peut attendre des
autres et de l'univers général tout
comme le grain de sable l'être humain ne
peut pas ne pas être la chose qu'il est
il ne peut pas ne pas être rationnel
c'est à dire qu'il est constitué par les
structures de l'univers et que celle ci
le conduisent justement aller refléter
on peut dire que l'univers pense et que
la manière dont ils pensent et la
manière dont nous nous exprimons le
principe rationnelle qui régit l'univers
conduit l'être humain à réfléchir dans
les deux sens du terme
il y réfléchit et il le réfléchi l'être
humain est cette chose qui reflète
l'ordre rationnelle du cosmos il est
déterminé à penser et s'exprimer
selon l'ordre qui régit l'univers mais
cela ne veut pas dire qu'il ne dévie
jamais du chemin que dicte la raison on
l'a dit les stoïciens pense que les
corps célestes et non pas les êtres
humains sont les paradigmes de la
rationalité
contrairement aux astres qui ne dirait
jamais de leur parcours prédéterminé
l'être humain fait des erreurs plutôt
régulièrement que rarement d'ailleurs
mais parce qu'il ne peut pas échapper à
sa condition rationnel il ne peut pas ne
pas se rendre compte de sa déviation du
droit chemin et cela nous permet
d'affirmer un qu'il peut progresser
deux qu'il doit progresser et 3 qu'il ne
peut pas pour autant viser la
rationalité des arts pour les stoïciens
le but de la vie humaine et de vivre en
conformité avec la nature comment y
parvenir
la réponse c'est ce qu'on pourrait
appeler une théorie du développement
naturel de la raison humaine
ils décrivent un processus voilà le
point de départ
nous naissons avec l' envie d'aller vers
ce qui va nous permettre de préserver
notre état et avec l' envie de fuir ce
qui nous semble nuisibles ont grandi en
accumulent des expériences et on
progresse dans notre manière de
distinguer ce vers quoi il faut se
diriger ce qu'il faut fuir en
grandissant on se rapporte à nos parents
aux autres êtres humains et on reconnaît
en eux des états similaire au nôtre
on comprend que nous cherchons tous à
préserver la même chose l'état
rationnelle on comprend alors que c'est
la raison qui organise le monde et donc
quel est ce qui nous est le plus cher
on fait tout pour la préserver vivre en
conformité avec la nature s'est
développée la place de la raison dans
son existence
la question n'est donc pas comment
parvenir à vivre selon la nature mais
plutôt comment ne pas y parvenir
c'est à dire que fait-on qui nous fait
dévié du chemin naturel il faut
identifier
la raison de nos erreurs alors hein on
étudie le monde pour voir la raison à
l'oeuvre dans la réalité on identifie en
toute chose le travail structurant de la
raison on essaye de comprendre la raison
aussi précisément que possible et 2 on
s'entraîne à agir et penser de la
manière la plus conforme à ce que l'on
sait de la raison puisque du point de
vue de la raison ma vie a autant
d'importance que celle d'un autre
ce développement de la raison dans
l'existence de l'individu est censée
mener un cosmopolitisme vertueux on
devient tout aussi concernée par sa
propre représentation que par celle de
tout autre instrument
au point où notre compréhension du monde
peut nous amener à sacrifier notre
propre vie pour la préservation d'un
autre si les conséquences de son
maintien en vie sont de plus grande
valeur et ses conséquences sont
incalculables
puisque tout est déterminé par la
causalité on peut donc dire que notre
compréhension du monde doit déterminer
notre comportement c'est une exigence
magnifique soit dit en passant
combien de décisions sont prises au
niveau individuel ou collectif notamment
par des gouvernements
à rebours de ce que l'on sait du
fonctionnement du monde on a dit que
chez les stoïciens l'univers était
tissée de chaîne causale chaque action
chaque événement est le résultat d'un
nombre incalculable de cause qui se sont
succédé les unes aux autres pour être
plus précis il faudrait dire que chaque
événement est le résultat d'un
croisement de plusieurs chaîne causale
c'est dans la reconnaissance de cette
complexité que la liberté de l'être
humain va pouvoir s'exprimer
notre marge de manoeuvre réside dans le
fait de gérer la tension entre le
déterminisme et la conscience de ce
déterminisme plus on est capable de
comprendre les connexions causale qui
détermine une situation particulière
plus on est libre mais attention cette
liberté n'est pas celle de pouvoir
changer la situation
au contraire il s'agit de s'y plier ça
peut sembler contre intuitif mais c'est
une position qu'on trouve aussi chez
spinoza ou dans le bouddhisme la
reconnaissance des causes produit une
expérience de libération
cela veut dire que la liberté se trouve
dans notre compréhension de ce qui lie
notre représentation du réel à la
complexité du réel lui même pour le dire
plus simplement si nous comprenons
pourquoi nous voyons les choses de la
manière dont nous les voyons nous nous
libérons un de la manière dont nous
voyons les choses donc de notre propre
regard et 2d chose elle-même ou disons
de la partie de la chose qui dépend de
notre regard sa capacité à nous affecter
à donner du sens à notre expérience et
talent ainsi les stoïciens n'enseigne
pas la suppression des émotions mais
plutôt la transformation de notre
rapport à elle afin de ne pas agir sur
nos émotions et sur la part neutre et
objective de nos représentations
il s'agit de faire une distinction
au sein de l'expérience entre la jouer
motifs subjectifs qu'il faudrait mettre
de côté et le jugement sur ce qui est
vrai ou faux c'est ce dernier qui doit
déterminer notre décision
on ne peut espérer éviter totalement les
émotions mais on peut éviter de se
laisser duper parce qu'elles nous font
croire l'esprit réflexif se détacher des
émotions brutes et décider si elles sont
appropriées et donc si c'est une bonne
idée de les cultiver ou non les
stoïciens distinguer le pro pathos la
réaction instinctive de los patos les
sentiments issu d'un jugement réfléchi
et le but est d'atteindre une forme de
détachement lucide et stoïciens font une
distinction fondamentale entre les
choses qui sont en notre pouvoir et
celles qui ne le sont pas la première
catégorie comprend essentiellement nos
pensées et nos attitudes alors que la
seconde comprend à peu près tout le
reste
l'idée c'est que l'appel d'esprit
émergent lorsqu'on ne se concentre que
sur ce que nous pouvons contrôler plutôt
que de gaspiller son énergie
émotionnelle à se focaliser sur ce que
l'on ne peut pas contrôler savoir
distinguer ce qui dépend de nous de ce
qui échappe à notre contrôle et le
principal levier de libération cela
implique la pratique d'une indifférence
vis-à-vis de tout ce qui ne dépend pas
de soi indifférence au succès ou à
l'échec de ce qu'on entreprend
indifférence à la perte de ce que l'on
possède
puisque cela peut arriver à tout moment
et qu'on ne contrôle pas la chaîne
causale qui régissent le monde
l'exemple le plus célèbre c'est epictète
le philosophe esclaves impassible face
aux tortures que lui a infligé son
maître lui faisant simplement remarquer
que s'il continue ainsi il finira par
lui casser la jambe ce qui en effet
arrive à cet exemple incarne
l'injonction stoïcienne en ce sens
précis epictète n'attache aucun ajout
émotif ou affectif
à l'énoncé pure et simple de la réalité
des faits la situation est comme réduit
à la validation du jugement selon lequel
à force de torture une jambe qu'ils
chassent casse
il faut éviter un malentendu courant qui
tend à croire que l'indifférence polie
sienne serait une attitude anti sociale
ou égocentrique il s'agit bien sûr
d'accepter de comprendre le monde pour
pouvoir en jouir sans en dépendre mais
la vie vertueuse qui est la vie heureuse
et livre suppose d'avoir compris par le
travail de la raison que l'homme né dans
le monde
une partie ni plus ni moins importante
que tout autre participant à toutes les
lois races naines ne sont pas là pour
l'homme il a la possibilité d'en
profiter pour atteindre 7 livres
heureuse mais cela ne conduit pas à des
conclusions de mégalo au contraire
l'usagé de la raison pousse vers plus
d'humilité
ainsi les stoïciens envisage tout
naturellement une égalité des facultés
entre hommes et femmes au nom d'une
égalité totale d'accès à la raison la
seule valeur qui compte la femme a donc
contrairement aux stéréotypes
généralement misogyne sur l'antiquité
les mêmes possibilités d'atteindre la
verticale hommes c'est un point non
négligeable qui soulignent la pertinence
de la position stoïcienne pas seulement
parce que la misogynie paraît toujours
plus archaïque à mesure que le temps
passe mais aussi parce que tirer les
conséquences de ses propres raisonnement
au delà des moeurs de son temps démontre
une cohérence à toute épreuve pour le
stoïcisme tout ce qui existe à un corps
et seuls les corps peuvent agir être un
corps humain s'est inspiré marchés
fermés aussi et surtout penser cette
action-là appartient à un accord
particulier la main entièrement
rationnelle elle est le corps passif qui
reçoit les données sensorielles et en
même temps le corps actif qui les
organisent et les juges
c'est à dire que la connaissance
commence par l'empreinte de l'objet dans
l'âme comme le cachet dans la cire c'est
une affection passive donc une passion
que l'âme subi mais qu'elle juge
immédiatement pour en valider ou non le
contenu ce jugement aiguillera
l'individu à agir ou réagir d'une
manière ou d'une autre
imaginons qu'un père apprend que son
fils est mort l'âme du père va
transformer le fait en annonces et
émotif 7 et rim
mon fils est mort
ce qui s'accompagne donc de l'expérience
d'émotion l'énoncé qui décrit le fait
pure est altéré par son interprétation
en termes d'émotion les stoïciens voilà
une distorsion émotive de nos
représentations du réel
ce n'est pas que l'esprit soit envahie
d'un contenu irrationnel le cliché
serait de penser que le stoïcien
considère que le père louis de raisonner
au contraire le stoïcien direct
l'émotion est un mauvais jugement mais
un jugement tout de même il procède
d'une confusion autour des causes
cette tristesse est un raisonnement mais
un mauvais raisonnement pour éviter le
supplément émotionnel il faut refuser de
valider une des représentations mentales
pour le dire autrement on pourrait
présenter les choses ainsi
l'erreur de jugement qui conduit le père
à la tristesse c'est d'avoir compté sur
le fait que son fils reste en vie c'est
à dire précisément de s'être comporté
comme si le maintien en vie de son fils
était sous contrôle
si chaque jour de sa vie ils s'étaient
attendus à ce que son fils puisse mourir
d'un instant à l'autre son traitement de
l'événement
mon fils est mort reproduit une autre
forme de jugement donc une autre forme
d'émotion
il s'agit de raisonner sur ses propres
mouvements de l'âme les émotions ne sont
en fait que des jugements rationnel que
nous n'avons pas suffisamment ajustées à
notre compréhension du réel et des
causes qui le déterminent elles tiennent
à des représentations erronées de l'état
du monde
le travail de ces représentations est au
coeur du stoïcisme
car comme on disait au début le
stoïcisme c'est une philosophie pratique
rien d'étonnant donc à ce que les
stoïciens et inventer des exercices pour
stimuler le développement naturel de la
raison pour s'entraîner à mieux vivre
pierre hadot les appels exercices
spirituels
car à son sens le mot spirituel permet
de faire entendre que ces exercices sont
l'oeuvre non seulement de la pensée mais
de tout le psychisme de l'individu pour
les stoïciens rappelons le le malheur
des hommes tient au fait qu'on cherche à
atteindre des choses qu'on n'arrivera
pas à obtenir qu'on cherche à garder des
choses qu'on risque de perdre ou qu'on
cherche à éviter des mots inévitable la
philosophie va nous transformer pour
contre cherche à atteindre que ce que
l'on peut effectivement obtenir et qu'on
ne cherche à éviter que ce qu on peut
effectivement éviter leur est donc ce
qui ne dépend pas nous correspond à
l'enchaînement nécessaire des causes et
des effets ça nous échappent et ça doit
donc nous être indifférent il faut
prendre le mot au pied de la lettre
nous ne devons pas y introduire de
différence nous devons l'accepter tout
entier comme si c'était le destin changé
son regard à ce point est difficile
c'est précisément là que doivent
intervenir les exercices spirituels
car il ne suffit pas de savoir
théoriquement il faut pratiquer le
savoir pour l'intégrer il faut se le
représenter pour se transformer pour
adopter la philosophie stoïcienne comme
une manière spontanée d'expérimenter
l'existence s'imprégner des croyances
que l'on sait rationnelle pour modifier
la manière qu'ils ont à d'éprouver sa
vie voilà une réelle ambition
philosophique malheureusement il ne
reste pas beaucoup de traces autour de
ces exercices
on sait quels textes les classe selon
les trois facultés de l'âme la faculté
désir la faculté d'action la faculté de
penser
il conseille de faire les exercices avec
discrétion et sans ostentation
il existe également un petit traité de
l'exercice de musso news refusent ils
recommandent l'exercice physique comme
s'habitue aux intempéries à la faim et à
la soif car cela rend l'âme plus forte
il y a aussi des exercices propres à
l'âme
qui consiste à s'imprégner des
démonstrations et principe se rapportant
à la distinction entre vrais et faux
bien vrai et faux mal pour ne plus
craindre ce que la plupart des hommes
considèrent comme des mots la pauvreté
la souffrance la mort grâce à philon
d'alexandrie nous possédons de lys
d'exercice je pense vers une vidéo
bientôt spécifiquement centré sur la
description de ces exercices
mais je vous en présente justin pour
piquer votre curiosité une méditation
appelé préméditation malraux elle
consiste à se représenter en avance les
difficultés de la vie
la pauvreté la souffrance la mort on les
imagine aussi précisément que possible
on les visualise et on se les représente
comme des choses inévitable pour se
préparer à leur survenue un intérêt non
philosophique pour les potentialités
thérapeutique du stoïcisme est né à la
fin du xxème siècle et au début du 21e
siècle
il semble y avoir les affinités entre le
rôle que les stoïciens accorde aux
jugements et les principes des thérapies
cognitivo comportementale ce n'est pas
dans ce format que j'aborde
explicitement les enjeux politiques des
concepts ou les théories philosophiques
généralement c'est plutôt pour le format
blanc pour autant je veux profiter de
cette vidéo pour préciser quelque chose
puisque ce regain d'intérêt qui déborde
désormais les tcc pour envahir les
vidéos de coaching sur youtube n'est pas
anodin il semble s'inscrire dans la
dynamique plus général qui célèbre la
résilience
or une telle célébration a une portée
politique évidente puisqu'elle fait
reposer la responsabilité du bonheur sur
l'individu plutôt que sur la capacité de
l'état à produire les conditions de
possibilité de ce bonheur on comprend
alors comment et pourquoi une
philosophie comme le stoïcisme se trouve
coincé entre deux feux dans le monde
contemporain
la philosophie invite souvent à se
changer soi même plutôt qu'à changer le
monde et cela peut sembler incompatible
avec l'idée d'une lutte contre
l'injustice
ainsi certain enthousiasme autour des
stoïciens donne l'impression de le
réduire à un moyen pour devenir
individuellement plus fort on oublie
peut-être que le stoïcisme doit
déboucher sur une plus grande humilité
et sur la conscience que la vie d'autrui
vaut autant que la mienne atteindre la
vie heureuse stoïcienne devrait conduire
une fois donc débarrassé de notre
égocentrisme naik à une plus grande
préoccupation pour l'autre
les stoïciens insistait sur le fait de
cultiver ces vertus morales pour devenir
quelqu'un de bien et les quatre vertus
cardinales était la sagesse le courage
la justice et la tempérance être
vraiment fort pour un stoïcien
c'est se libérer de soi même et c'est
cette libération qui devrait nous
permettre de lutter pour la justice